[Music]
[Applause]
i've always had a fascination for
computers and technology
and i made a few apps for the iphone
ipod touch and ipad
i'd like to share a couple with you
today
my first app was a unique fortune teller
called earth fortune
that would display different colors of
earth depending on what your fortune was
my favorite and most successful app is
busting jeeber which is which is a
justin bieber whack-a-mole
i created it because a lot of people at
school
disliked justin bieber a little bit so i
decided to
make the app so i went to work
programming it
and i released it just before the
holidays in 2010.
a lot of people ask me how did i make
these
a lot of times it's because the person
who asked the question wants to make an
apt
also a lot of kids these days like to
play games
but now they want to make them and it's
difficult
because not many kids know where to go
to find out how to make a program i mean
for soccer you could go to a soccer team
for violin you could get lessons for a
violin
but what if you want to make an app and
their parents
kids parents might have done some of
these things when they were young but
not many parents have written abs
where do you go to find out how to make
an app well this is how i approached it
this is what i did
first of all i've been programming in
multiple
other programming languages to get the
basics down
such as python c java et cetera
and then apple released the iphone and
with it the iphone
software development kit and the
software development kit
is a suite of tools for creating and
programming
an iphone app this opened up a whole new
world of possibilities for me
and after playing with the software
development kit a little bit i made a
couple
apps i made some test apps one of them
happened to be earth fortune and i was
ready to put earth fortune on the app
store
and so i persuaded my parents to pay the
fee to be able to put my apps on the app
store
they agreed and now i have apps on the
app store
i've gotten a lot of interest and
encouragement from my family friends
teachers and even people at the apple
store and that's been a huge help to me
i've got a lot of inspiration from steve
jobs
and i started an app club at school
and a teacher at my school is kindly
sponsoring my app club
any student at my school can come and
design
learn how to design an app
this is so i can share my experiences
with with others
there's these programs called the ipad
pilot program
and some districts have them i'm
fortunate enough to be part of one
a big challenge is how should the ipads
be used and what apps
should we put on the ipads so we're
getting feedback from teachers
at the school to see what kind of apps
they'd like
when we design the app and we sell it it
will be free to local districts
and other districts that we sell to
all the money from that will go into the
local ed foundations
these days students know usually know a
little bit more than teachers
with the technology
[Music]
so
sorry
so this is a resource to teachers and
educators
should recognize this resource and make
good use of it
i'd like to finish up by seeing what i
like to do in the future
first of all i'd like to create more
apps more games
i'm working with a third-party company
to make an app
i like to get into android programming
and development
and i'd like to continue my app club and
find other ways
for students to share knowledge with
others thank you